oh non rien de présenter son Honor Magic
5 Pro alors c'est un smartphone qu'on
attendait depuis longtemps et on
attendait de voir où aller nous emmener
au nord là-dessus parce que l'année
dernière souvenez-vous le Magic 4 pro
était très bon c'était un vrai step up
pour Honor qui allait vers le Premium la
premiumisation et c'est génial et là
justement et bien il y a une vraie
confirmé signé avec des choses super
intéressantes donc aujourd'hui on fait
quoi on est ici au MWC à Barcelone au
Nord vient d'officialiser son Magic 5
Pro alors il y a une gamme le Magic 5
mais qui sortira pas en France le Magic
5 Lite je voulais déjà présenté la vidéo
et sur ma chaîne youtube allez jeter un
coup d’œil et le Magic vs c'est le
smartphone qui se plie de Honor qui
arrive également je voulais présenter au
mois de décembre donc ça on connaît
c'est très très chouette et puis surtout
ce Magic 5 Pro c'est la nouvelle version
très haut de gamme de Honor l'évolution
du Magic 4 pro et je vous le dis
franchement ils sont comparés pendant
tout le temps au Samsung Galaxy S23
ultra qui est quelque part ici dans ma
poche et qui est vraiment il faut le
dire un excellent smartphone un
excellent photophone et qui est
peut-être un des meilleurs smartphones
de l'année je dis ça l'année vient de
commencer on verra ça à la fin de
l'année on fera les comptes à la fin et
puis on regardera qu'est-ce qu'il
raconte bien évidemment mais
ultérieurement dans une autre vidéo donc
pensez à vous abonner c'est pas déjà
fait on regardera qu'elle est le
meilleur photophone entre le Honor Magic
5 Pro il y a également le Xiaomi 13 pro
qui est intéressant il y a ce Samsung
Galaxy S23 ultra qui est hyper cool que
j'ai déjà testé donc je vais tout vous
dire sur ce Honor Magic 5 Pro ce que
vous êtes prêt on y va
[Musique]
bon la première chose qu'on va venir
faire c'est l'ouvrir on est dans les
extérieurs du MWC on va se trouver un
petit coin tranquille sans l'ouvrir de
le regarder et bien évidemment de tout
vous raconter ok alors regardez on va
ouvrir le smartphone mon labo est très
classique donc on passe rapidement on
arrive déjà là dessus alors moi ce que
j'aime bien c'est ce design que je
trouve extrêmement efficace ils ont
vraiment joué la symétrie ça qui est
assez intéressant au niveau de ce
smartphone l'année dernière c'est l'oeil
de la muse là ils sont dû sortir une
référence par rapport à gaouji on est à
Barcelone en Espagne peut-être un peu
pour ça il y a effectivement des petites
courbes la très légères et on va
retrouver si on se met un peu de profil
comme ça c'est gros bloc photo central
avec un grand angle là du très
grand-angle et puis un zoom périscopique
jusqu'à x 100 c'est l'équivalent du
Space zoom de Samsung qu'on va venir
retrouver ici après le reste est assez
sympa alors en France il y a deux
couleurs qui sort vous avez soit ce
petit verre comme ça qui est très joli
soit un noir qui est j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a un peu plus brillant qui
potentiellement pour laisser davantage
de traces de doigts alors à l'intérieur
de la boîte on va venir retrouver quoi
on a un bloc de charge ça c'est pas mal
ils nous ont laissé ici c'est de la
super charge au nord on est sur de la 66
watts donc de la recharge rapide quand
même qui est signée au nord c'est plutôt
pas mal avec d'un côté de l'usba de
l'autre côté de l'usb-c qu'on va venir
retrouver ici bien évidemment au niveau
du petit câble et puis c'est à peu près
tout je crois qu'il y a une petite coque
mais bon des fois on sait pas si elles y
seront dans les versions commerciales
quand on a des versions comme ça presse
on est pas sûr bon voilà ça c'est simple
c'est efficace en terme de prise en main
je trouve plutôt bien alors bon il est
quand même assez large pas le tour
complet avec maman faut pas dire que
j'ai des très grosses paluche mais
globalement ça va quand même plutôt bien
c'est un smartphone qui fait 219 g et
qui rentre un peu dans l'idée des
smartphones d'aujourd'hui qui sont quand
même assez grand assez épais c'est vrai
que le bloc ici photo vient quand même
l'épaissir pas trop trop mal le reste
est un peu plus fin il rentre dans ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui des
smartphones premium donc ici pas de
mauvaise surprise regardez ce qui est
intéressant c'est au niveau de la partie
photo vous avez deux emplacements on va
voir une caméra principale bien
évidemment je vous parle de la partie
photo tout à l'heure au niveau de la
fiche technique mais vous avez une
première partie pour votre caméra de
selfie une deuxième partie pour la
caméra 3D parce qu'ici on peut venir
déverrouiller grâce à la reconnaissance
trois dimensions de votre visage donc ça
c'est quand même vachement bien ça
change du feuilleton 2D un peu classique
ça veut dire sécuriser davantage en plus
de ça on va venir déverrouiller avec son
capteur d'empreinte digitale si on le
souhaite bref il est pas sur le côté il
est pas sur la tranche il intégrer ici
dans la partie centrale la première
chose à venir voir cet écran qui est
super intéressant c'est que c'est un
écran qui est incurvé des quatre côtés
il est incurvé sur le côté à gauche à
droite mais également un curvé en bas
aussi incurvé en haut qui va donner un
côté un peu plus de profondeur
personnellement je trouve vraiment sympa
on est sur une dalle qui fait 6,80
ampoule c'est du ltpo ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire déjà d'une que vous avez un
taux de rafraîchissement variable qui va
jusqu'à 120 Hertz ça c'est plutôt cool
là je le mets en dynamique ça fait que
je suis à 120 Hertz maximum et je vais
descendre beaucoup plus bas normalement
s'ils l'ont pas dit mais le LTP vraiment
va descendre jusqu'à 1 h si si pour
venir économiser de l'énergie notamment
lorsque vous êtes sur du alway zone
display vous lisez un article des choses
comme ça ça c'est plutôt bien c'est un
smartphone qui a une résolution de 2048
par 1312 pixels à 461 pixels par pouce
on a un milliard de couleur une gamme de
couleurs dci P3 hdr10 plus bref on a
tout ce qu'on attend d'un smartphone
extrêmement haut de gamme sur le marché
en plus de ça c'est un truc qui est
intéressant c'est que au nord ils ont
plein de petites technologies qui
viennent nous mettre dans ce smartphone
il nous annonce un pic de luminosité à
1800 Nitz OK et puis surtout nous disent
des choses vachement intéressantes
lorsque vous allez l'utiliser qui a un
petit peu moins de lumière lorsque avec
le soir déjà il est certifié lutter
contre la lumière bleue par toveryland
donc ça c'est quand même plutôt cool
donc ça veut dire qu'on vient pas se
flinguer les yeux lorsqu'on vient de
regarder et puis en plus de ça il vient
minimiser le scintillement lorsque vous
allez le mettre en faible luminosité
lorsque vous êtes le soir et bien vous
vous dites tiens il y a un petit peu
moins de lumière hop là je vais baisser
la luminosité de mon smartphone et bien
pour éviter les faits sentiments et que
vous en rendez pas compte vous mais ça
vous fatiguez les yeux et que ça vous
les abîme à force et bien lui il va
venir travailler là-dessus pour éviter
cet effet on s'y sentiments ce côté un
peu flipper qui est un peu relou alors
après il y a un autre truc qui est
intéressant également c'est qu'il vient
s'adapter par rapport à votre cycle de
sommeil en gros ce qui se passe c'est
que lorsque vous regardez votre écran le
soir ça va empêcher la production de
mélatonine qui est l'hormone qui vous
sert à vous endormir et ça va retarder
le moment où vous allez vous endormir
ils vont mettre en place une techno qui
va éviter le retard de production de la
mélatonine ce qui fait que si vous êtes
fatigué vous allez pouvoir vous endormir
avec votre smartphone il y a pas de
souci donc voilà plein de petites techno
super intéressantes ici au niveau de
l'écran il y a également une technologie
de gradation dynamique qui va venir
simuler la lumière naturelle ils ont
plus ou des technologies pour venir
améliorer l'image notamment le super
dynamique vide display en gros ça va
apporter des couleurs un petit peu plus
tonique un peu plus saturé à encore une
fois de plus là je découvre donc je vous
dis ce qui nous raconte donc on
regardera ça dans le détail un peu plus
tard disent également qu'ils vont venir
augmenter le nombre d'images par seconde
si par exemple vous êtes sur un 30
images par seconde et bah oui ils vont
venir en rajouter les doubler pour
monter un 60 images par seconde lorsque
vous allez venir regarder du contenu
donc plus fluide et plus doux pour vos
yeux et surtout il a le score le plus
haut aujourd'hui chez dxmark avec le
score de 151 au niveau de l'écran ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est le top
écran chez DX remarque ici on a des
haut-parleurs stéréo du Bluetooth 5.2
bref plein de technologie pour venir
maximiser l'expérience multimédia au
niveau de l'audio ça c'est super
intéressant une fois de plus on
vérifiera ça et je vous dirai ce que
j'en pense les phases de test mais que
sur un smartphone trio de gamme sans une
très grosse plus très performante alors
pas très grosse parce qu'il y a toute
petite elle est gravée en quatre
nanomètres c'est le sladragon 8 Jane II
que je vous ai déjà présenté lorsque je
vous ai emmené au mois de décembre avec
moi voyager pour le découvrir c'est
aujourd'hui une puce qui fonctionne
super bien basé sur de l'intelligence
artificielle qui cartonne donc ici pour
moi il y a absolument aucun problème
j'ai déjà testé notamment chez Xiaomi
notamment chez Samsung il y a pas de
problème de chauffe ça marche bien c'est
bien en plus de ça ils sont venus mettre
des techno hyper forte et hyper bonne au
niveau de la RAM vous avez 12 Go de RAM
c'est de la lpdr 5x dernière techno qui
va très très bien et puis au niveau du
stockage ils ont 6000 paquets 512 Go de
stockage c'est de l'uefs 4.0 alors
aujourd'hui je sais pas s'il extensible
ou pas de vous à moi je pense qu'il est
pas extensible on vérifiera ça bien
évidemment un peu plus tard je voudrais
l'ouvrir on regardera ça ensemble bref
je vous dirai tout et puis il y a plein
d'autres technologies que maîtrise au
nord et qui viennent vous mettre ici
également notamment le GPU turbo pour
venir booster toute la partie graphique
on a également l'os turbo x bref plein
de techno qui viennent maximiser
l'expérience et rendre votre smartphone
encore plus puissant encore plus
performant pour que vous essayez de
toute façon totalement invisible pour
vous vous ayez une bête de campagne dans
les mains c'est un smartphone qui a une
grosse batterie de 5100 milliampères
heure je vous l'ai dit auraient de la
recharge rapide 66 watts et puis on peut
avoir de la recharge sans fil 50 watts
alors le truc qui est intéressant et je
vous l'ai dit au nord il a beaucoup
comparé au Galaxy S23 ultra de Samsung
ils nous ont fait un match c'est le leur
attention il nous annonce deux heures
d'autonomie en plus que Samsung on
regardera ça bien évidemment mais sur le
papier en tout cas je dois reconnaître
que c'est assez alléchant l'expérience
logiciel c'est Magic QI 7.1 basé sur
l'Android 13 alors si vous connaissez
l'expérience de hon ça c'est clair c'est
lisible tout est séparé avec des icônes
de couleur bien évidemment comme c'est
de l'Android S c'est totalement
personnalisable et c'est très très cool
on peut faire plein plein de trucs un
bon je vais vous montrer très très
rapidement si vous venez regarder par
exemple dans l'affichage et luminosité
vous allez avoir un thème clair un thème
sombre ok c'est joli ça c'est bien vous
avez également un mode ebook si vous
voulez venir lire et ça c'est très très
cool le confort des yeux et du sommeil
ça c'est pour le soir c'est bien c'est
pratique mode de température de couleur
pour venir régler ici normal et vive je
vous recommande le vif je trouve ça
quand même vachement plus joli la
résolution vous pouvez venir choisir
soit en LG soit en standard ça vient
jouer bien évidemment sur l'autonomie de
votre smartphone la fréquence également
de rafraîchissement de votre écran je
vous ai montré ça tout à l'heure bref il
y a plein d'options alors là c'est la
partie affichage vous avez également la
partie fond d'écran pour venir
customiser avec plein de petites options
pour moi c'est une expérience qui est
claire qui est lisible qui marche bien à
voir si vous vous y trouvez votre
bonheur mais pour moi et c'est pas de
mauvaise surprise l'expérience aussi au
niveau de la partie photo fonctionne
très très bien je vais déjà montré
sachez au nord avec la partie photo la
partie film vous avez plein de petits
trucs en plus vous pouvez venir à voir
ici la Super Macro le Time Lapse la
storia la partie vidéo la partie photo
le mode portrait bref pas mal de choses
et justement parce que je vous montre la
partie logiciel pour les photos et bien
je vais vous parler maintenant de la
partie matériel pour la photo photo et
vidéo vous allez voir franchement c'est
plutôt pas mal vous avez trois capteurs
ici 50 mégapixels vous avez un grand
angle de 50 mégapixels en ouvrant f1.6
ici c'est plutôt pas mal on a un ultra
grand-angle de 50 mégapixels F 2.0 avec
un champ de vision de 122 degrés puis
vous avez la téléobjectif avec un zoom
périscopique ici qui ouvre f3.0 avec un
zoom optique x 3,5 et on va jusqu'à un
zoom numérique jusqu'au bout hein x 100
c'est écrit ici sans oublier le petit
laser ici qui vous permettra d'avoir un
mode portrait encore plus net alors je
vous le dis Franck billet ils ont mis le
paquet au niveau de la partie photo et
vidéo avec un très gros travail d'un
point de vue logiciel alors pas à votre
logiciel à vous que vous allez venir
piloter mais le logiciel interne du
smartphone ça veut dire que il vous
annonce qu'il y a une technologie qui
permet d'avoir la meilleure photo
lorsque vous allez venir shooter et bien
lui il vous permettra de sélectionner la
meilleure photo en action ça c'est super
intéressant à voir effectivement lors du
test également ça c'est l'algorithme
capture on a également de la macro bon
la macro c'est pas très surprenant mais
on peut venir shooter en macro ici on
verra une fois de plus si c'est bien ou
pas lors du test très bientôt donc
pensez à bien vous abonner il y a la
technologie
ultra fusion qu'ils avaient déjà
présenté l'année dernière sur le Magic 4
pro qui va venir regrouper des éléments
de photos faites avec différents
capteurs pour venir totalement maximiser
votre photo donc on la retrouve
également ici alors c'est déjà une
technologie qu'on connaissait avant mais
qu'on retrouve une fois de plus ici et
surtout surtout le truc qui est dingue
c'est qu'on retrouve un top score dxmark
au niveau de la photo à 152 ce qui le
place aujourd'hui chez DxO marque c'est
la meilleure note au niveau de la photo
donc une fois de plus on regardera ça
parce que peut-être probablement c'est
peut-être ça je sais que il travaille
énormément derrière et qu'il faut un
boulot de dingue mais c'est vrai que
j'ai adoré le travail café hop là je le
ressort ici Samsung avec son Galaxy S23
ultra j'ai trouvé excellent on va voir
si justement le Honor Magic 5 Pro arrive
à lui emboîter le pas à être aussi bon
voir un meilleur en tout cas des X-Max
semble penser que oui avec le top score
de 152 on verra ça ensemble très bientôt
et continue sur leur lancer au niveau de
la vidéo avec de la 4K et si vous êtes
un créateur et que vous avez besoin en
plus shooter en loge pour avoir une
image extrêmement flat et bien vous
pouvez venir shooter en log 10 bits 4K
60 et ça une fois de plus pour les gens
comme moi qui aiment faire de la vidéo à
faire smartphone c'est une excellente
nouvelle IP68 on a une double sim plus
une ici tout ça en 5G bien évidemment du
NFC pour le paiement des matérialisé et
du wi-fi si donc vous avez un cocktail
gagnant aujourd'hui en terme de
connectivité bref vous avez un truc qui
marche très bien ils ont fait aussi un
très gros focus sur la sécurité avec
deux points la première c'est une puce
de sécurité de quoi comme qu'on va venir
retrouver à l'intérieur qui va venir
protéger vos données notamment vos
données biométriques on prend le
digitales reconnaissance de votre visage
en trois dimensions et compagnie puis un
deuxième point qui est intéressant c'est
une technologie Unia qui va venir éviter
lorsque vous appelez que les personnes
autour de vous puissent venir entendre
votre conversation on avait déjà la
première version l'année dernière on a
la nouvelle version cette année lorsque
vous passez votre coup de fil et bien le
son va être dirigé uniquement vers votre
oreille il va pas venir rayonner autour
de vous si bien que si quelqu'un se
trouve à côté de vous dans le train chez
vous j'en sais foutrement rien et bien
elle va pas pouvoir entendre ce qui sort
du haut parleur de votre téléphone et ça
une fois de plus extrêmement rassurant
alors nous en montrer un truc qui est
assez intéressant dans leur présentation
lors de leur conférence c'est une
contrôle de votre smartphone avec des
gestes alors je veux bien le croire
parce que vous avez une caméra 3D à la
vente votre smartphone ce qui bien que
la pouvoir venir reconnaître les gestes
en trois dimensions reconnaître ce qui
bouge ce qui se passe donc en fait ce
qui vous disent c'est que si par exemple
vous voulez venir scroller avec votre
map vous allez pouvoir venir scroller à
distance pas trop en fait du du
scrolling comme ça sans problème vous
allez pouvoir venir faire des captures
d'écran directement avec votre
smartphone donc ça il faut être plus je
dirais le regarder j'irai approfondir
pour vous et je dirais ce que j'en pense
donc je trouve ça assez marrant une fois
de plus comment est-ce qu'il vienne
utiliser cette caméra 3D non seulement
pour la sécurité avec la reconnaissance
de votre visage en trois dimensions mais
également pour pouvoir lui apporter des
fonctions un peu plus conviviales sympa
il est posé vous scrolez à distance
tranquille on va dire sans les mains
mais regarde sans le toucher donc ça ça
me plaît plutôt bien et c'est un
smartphone qui est disponible au tarif
de
1199 euros dans la version bien
évidemment il y en a qu'une seule c'est
la 12 giga de ram 512 giga de stockage
le Honor Magic 5 Pro on est une fois de
plus au dessus des 1000 euros mais on
s'en doutait 1199 €, alors est-ce que ça
pourrait vous tenter vous ce smartphone
est-ce vous verriez mettre 1199 € dans
le Honor Magic 5 Pro alors moi je vous
donne mon retour Fran billets à chaud
comme ça j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont
une fois de plus monté d'un cran avec
plein de petites technologies avec de
l'intelligence artificielle
l'optimisation au niveau de votre écran
d'une très jolie dalle je la vois là je
trouve vraiment très très belle et très
lumineuse alors là il faut pas dire
qu'on a un soleil de plomb tout de suite
à Barcelone mais pour autant l'écran je
trouve très sexy le smartphone je trouve
joli ce que j'aurais aimé ce que j'ai
pas et bien c'est des caméras intégrées
sous l'écran mais là une fois de plus il
y a pas que Honor qui aujourd'hui de la
propose pas réellement j'ai vu ZTE qu'il
propose mais ZTE en France et les
Inconnus donc bon ça va pas changer
grand chose ça va finir ce démocratiser
bientôt pour avoir et bien je dirais des
smartphones sans aucune bulle et encoche
ou poinçon bref ce que vous voulez mais
comme il est là il est joli j'aime bien
le côté immersif je sais qu'il y a
beaucoup de performances on va regarder
l'autonomie j'avais beaucoup aimé le
Magic 4 pro une année en photo j'avais
trouvé vraiment excellent on va voir si
ce magicien pro lui emboîte le pas mais
très honnêtement et vu les tops scores
ici au niveau de l'écran et au niveau de
la photo de dxomaque je doute pas que ce
soit un excellent smartphone pour le
côté divertissement pour le côté
création pour la créativité pour venir
s'amuser à 1199 €, est-ce que vous vous
seriez prêt à mettre 1199 euros dans un
smartphone de Honor dites-le-moi dans
les commentaires voilà vous savez tout
sur ce Honor Magic 5 Pro alors dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires est-ce que c'est un
smartphone qui pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce que vous avez envie d'aller
dessus est-ce qu'il vous fait de l'œil à
ce qu'il vous tente est-ce qu'il vous
aille pour marquer ça bien évidemment
juste en bas dans les commentaires et
puis nous on en parle très bientôt moi
personnellement je trouve ça intéressant
sur le papier attention je l'ai pas
testé j'ai découvert il y a pas
longtemps j'ai pris j'ai la voix j'ai
ouvert donc je connais pas grand-chose
ce qui m'intéresse c'est les promesses
qui sont faites et puis surtout vous
avez des X-Max qui vous donne de très
bons scores derrière donc à voir ce que
j'en pense comment je le ressens
qu'est-ce qu'il ressort d'un point de
vue un peu feeling ressenti de ce
smartphone donc d'ici quelques jours
vous aurez déjà mes premiers retours sur
la partie photo vidéo et puis on va
venir creuser davantage au niveau du
test il y a plein de choses à venir
raconter et puis après bien évidemment
il y aura les comparatifs regardez par
rapport aux autres modèles parce qu'on
est ici sur Aston dragon 8 GN2
exactement la même chose sur le Samsung
Galaxy S23 ultra exactement le même
processeur sur le Xiaomi 13 pro donc on
regardera lequel est le meilleur et
lequel on sent le mieux mais ça ça sera
dans quelques jours donc pensez à vous
abonner d'ici là je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et si vous avez des
questions idées suggestions
interrogation ça se passe en bas dans
les commentaires à bientôt prenez soin
de de vous embrasse Ciao
[Musique]